my name's claudia and i'm currently a
freshman at mit
i'm from south florida and now my
journey continues here
[Music]
my family is from the azores islands
which are in the middle of the atlantic
just knowing that where my family comes
from and the lack of education they've
built me up with such important skills
of interpersonal communication team
building leadership and now it's just my
turn to take this and put it in an
academic context
being a first generation high school
graduate first generation college
student i didn't really have that
background of really good testing skills
or just the role models around me to
really show me how to do things
academically getting the academic
support had to come from somewhere and
khan academy being online being free and
available having the sat prep even
pairing up with the college board i was
able to get accurate very very closely
related questions so when i was on the
test nothing was a surprise
whenever it's free it's open it's fair i
have that fire in my stomach that i know
that this is where i want to be this is
what i want to do i have so many
opinions and so many things i find wrong
with the world and i really know that
this is a place where i can grow learn
and gain even more skills to be able to
do just that
[Music]